the core thing to make it as a writer is
do you [ __ ] have something to say so
I I've hit number one before you realize
how little it actually means when you
look back at your life you're not going
to think about how much money you made
like success at the end of your life is
a crowded table one of the Stokes said
that uh poverty is not having too little
it's wanting more enough is the
wealthiest place you could possibly be
and one of the most powerful questions
in in medications Marcus is Are You
Afraid Of Death because you won't be
able to do this anymore all right guys
bang bang I've got Ryan here with me
Ryan I thought a great place to start a
conversation is this idea of reinvention
you've had uh what seems like many
different Milestones or paths in your
career uh and I wanted to know how you
think about those paths or those
different stops in your career you've
worked under different people you've
kind of had these different aspects why
did you continue to reinvent yourself
and how did you do it so successfully
yeah there's a there's a quote I like
that I'm forgetting the exact version of
it but it's basically that like to
become who you are you have to kill off
all these different selves right and I
feel like that maybe when someone looks
at my career they think about it as
being this sort of well he was this and
then he was this and then he was this
um I think about it more as I sort of
started as this collection of things I
had all these different interests and I
explored each one and I took them as far
as they could go but then uh either I
hit a dead end or I stop being
interested in it and then that part of
myself had to be killed off and so I had
a marketing career I had an
entrepreneurial career I had a you know
I've written about different topics but
I think it was all towards I don't want
to say a specialization but it was it
was towards sort of uh picking that one
sort of singular Lane which is what I
write about now so like I guess I would
just say that in retrospect these things
always look much clearer than they are
so like people people go like well you
were writing about marketing how did you
switch to writing about ancient
philosophy but the truth was I was
writing about ancient philosophy first
then I sold a marketing book which was
successful and sort of uh outshined the
other stuff then I went back to it so my
point is that uh you want to be careful
I think looking at someone's career and
going like well they obviously went from
this to this to this it that that
Clarity I think tends to reveal itself
only in the biography if you know what I
mean it makes complete sense one of my
favorite questions to ask people who are
on the internet in you know many
different facets is do you consider
yourself an author a Creator an
entrepreneur or something else like if
you have to pick one Identity or one way
that you think about your life what are
you well I I like the term Creator uh
and it seems it's new-ish right like I
think when I was starting even 10 15
years ago there you there was writers
authors uh filmmakers Etc the idea that
you would you would have to be
multi-disciplinary that you would have
to have skills in all these different
mediums that didn't exist so I do like
the idea of of a Creator and and uh
that's what I think I would tell someone
to Aspire to be as opposed to just
picking one thing but I I love books and
so I see myself as a writer and and even
the distinction between author writer uh
to me author tends to only be booked so
I I identify as a writer like and I and
when you look at the other stuff that I
do whether it's on the podcast or uh
YouTube or social media it to me it's
all fruit of the writing if I don't do
the writing if I'm not doing like sort
of focus creative work in the written
word none of the other stuff happened
if you have to have like a core
competency you know what I mean I think
the problem with being a Creator is
people think is this kind of like loose
thing like oh I'm an artist I just make
stuff and that that is part of it but
you you have to have like a core
competency it's like to be in the MMA or
to be a professional MMA fighter you
have to have one facet of your game that
you're like the best at you have to be
proficient in all the other uh domains
but if you're not like you don't have a
ground game or you're not a stand-up guy
or kickboxing guy like you're probably
gonna get your ass kicked yeah it's
fascinating to hear you say this uh
Jerry Seinfeld on a episode Tim Ferriss
talked about how comedy is really a
writing exercise and I feel like so much
of uh the content that gets created
maybe outside of just live interviews
and podcast form pretty much everything
else seems to be a writing exercise and
so do you feel like if you had to pick
one of the skills to be great at writing
is probably the thing that allows
everything else to kind of uh really
spruce up from them I I I do I think
great writing translates in all the
different mediums so like if I write an
article or a chapter in a book or a
concept in a book and it resonates I
what I then do is go okay well what's
the video version of this what's the
Tweet version of this you know what's
the Instagram Carousel version of this I
Look to translate it in those different
mediums but it has to first come from
like my preferred creative methodology
or or medium I I don't know if I would
necessarily choose writing I would say
writing chose me like that that's where
I'm most comfortable that's that's what
that that's how I express myself as a
human being you know maybe somebody else
for them first it starts with something
else I don't know I just know that if
you can really nail something in one
medium or one format and the core idea
or concept is good it can be pretty
easily translated like in traditional
bushing for instance like I write a book
and then it gets translated into
different languages it the rights get
sold to uh a Ukrainian publisher or
um uh a mandarin publisher or uh all
these different markets I don't even see
those books but they know if it works in
English chances are it's going to work
in India it's going to work in all these
different markets so that's kind of now
how I've come to think about social
media stuff is is like Tick Tock is not
a medium that I get particularly excited
about consuming content but I try I have
people on my team who help me take
what's worked say in one of my books and
then how do we how do we break that down
so it has the ability to take advantage
of the algorithm on Tick Tock so what's
interesting about this is if you were
creating just YouTube videos or other
types of digital content you could go
into the analytics you could see where
are people listening the most what does
it seem like people are dropping off and
be very data driven about it with a book
sure there's digital versions but for
the most part the physical book you have
no data so how do you actually go and
figure out what are the things that we
should take out of a book or out of a
blog post and turn it into a video or a
tick tock or any other format there is
some data I remember Tim Ferriss turned
me on to this you can pull up like in on
Kindle what the most uh highlighted
passages of a book are or what's the
quotes that get shared the most uh I I
often look at like what are the pages
that people share so like for for
instance the daily stoic uh it's one
page a day so people often post like the
pages of the books that they like so the
book is seven years old now we have a
sense of what the pages that people like
the most What entries get shared the
most and so that's that that is valuable
data but
um yeah I think maybe one of the things
that I love about writing books is that
you're
you're on a longer time span and a
uh less sort of
I don't even know what the word is but
but it it's it's not so data driven and
that allows you to think bigger picture
and I I think make when I'm writing a
book I'm trying to write a book that
will still be relevant in 10 years or in
15 years I think when people are
tweeting they're thinking about what's
trending right now and that's why so
much of what's on social media is
ephemeral and doesn't age very well you
know there's that expression aged like
milk uh I I think a lot of social media
ages prematurely because people are
trying to ride whatever the wave of the
moment is as opposed to trying to get to
something that truly connects with you
know people on a fundamentally human
level
you've got a team I've heard you say
somewhere around 10 people or so what do
those people do right like when somebody
sees a book come out how much of the
team was helping on Research or other
things and then how much of the team is
focused on maybe after the book is
published what you're doing on social
media or other parts of your business
yeah I so I have uh and obviously an
editor at my publisher I have my own
editor that I I work with uh so that
would be you know that's on the the
creative content side I have a research
assistant who helps me gather this stuff
but but the writing I would say is the
most solitary of of what I do it that's
what's coming from inside me what I'm
interested in it's the things that can't
it's the one part of it that really
can't be outsourced or uh scaled in any
way that that's the unique creative
expression in the same way that you know
for a musician like you got to go to the
studio and write what you want to talk
about uh and then everything else to me
is about scaling and translating and
stretching that material to me be as big
a market as possible so obviously I have
people on the social team I have people
on the video team I've got people uh
like I do this daily email so how does
that email actually get set up and
formatted and then uh you know sent out
uh I've got editors that that do the the
audio side of the stuff on the podcast
and the daily email as well so most of
the team that I set up is about sort of
taking that that singular creative act
and allowing me to scale it into as many
different Avenues as possible so I used
to always think that the creative work
was going to be the last thing that
machines could replace right this idea
that uh it would go after all of the
root memorization it would go after all
the tedious stuff and if you were
creative you had this like moat that a
machine could never uh come after and I
was talking to Billy recently uh who I
know works with you and he said you know
I've never heard Ryan talk about
artificial intelligence and obviously
with the rise of all the image
generation and kind of all this stuff
that now seems like wait maybe the
machines are pretty good at the creative
work how do you think about the
intersection between artificial
intelligence machines and writing like
if it's so solitary it's so creative for
you could it one day replace humans or
how do you think about that I don't you
know I have this weird experience with
artificial intelligence which one of the
things that I do it's sort of a creative
sort of practice is whenever I read a
book so like I I go through them and I
take notes uh based on the the stuff
that I like and then I usually go and
I'm either writing those down by hand on
note cards which is you know what I use
for my research but sometimes I'll type
it out because I want to print up the
quotes like too long for me to do by
hand so I'll type it up and sometimes I
just type it in Gmail uh and you know
when you're using Gmail it it tries to
suggest to you where it thinks you're
going with that sentence with with uh
with artificial intelligence now when
when you're writing an email to you and
your friends and you're like hey do you
want to get together tomorrow it it's
like evening right it's it it's pretty
good at guessing where you're gonna go
you know it says like thanks for your
time you know it gets the sort of
cliches or the the basic ins and outs of
language which is it's kind of
remarkable and a little bit creepy be
and and it does save you a little bit of
time but I found as I type these quotes
and I've typed out you know quotes from
Hemingway and Fitzgerald and all the
great writers uh in history uh it is
never guessed the end of a truly great
sentence right uh and so maybe I'm
deluding myself but my view would be it
can it can get sort of humdrum uh Basics
just in the way that it can guess okay
you sent me an email about getting
together uh Google can tell me whether
it can ask whether I want to add that to
my calendar or not but can it actually
create a a truly unique uh profound
insight about this Human Experience I
have yet to see that
um and and I you know maybe it can at
some point uh and and obviously as as
creators that that's going to be an
alarming uh you know sort of uh uh
moment but but I do think what what that
would do is just force us as human
beings
I think a lot of what we do tend to talk
about is pretty basic and not that
interesting I think it's going to force
us to actually have to get more
vulnerable get you know better in touch
with ourselves you know uh be more
Fearless with what we write like it's
just going to force us to go to the
things that the machine can't uh nail
which is like sort of who we truly are
uh and what we truly think about it's
interesting that you're saying it this
way because I saw someone on Twitter
talking about the fact that uh people
who aren't actually artistic now can
simply become artists using some of
these image generators and things like
that and it puts a higher value on ideas
like the the old saying of you know
ideas are worthless it's all about
execution for an artist it used to be
like you can have all the ideas but like
can you paint can you actually create
this now if you can simply type in an
idea it may be able to do the execution
for you which kind of changes the
relationship between ideas execution you
know creative work and how people have
thought about where the value lies no I
think that's right although I've always
argued that uh while execution is
certainly important brilliant execution
without a good idea is essentially
worthless you know like uh the the the
core thing to to make it as a writer is
not you know how good you are at
marketing although if you're bad at
marketing you're probably not going to
make it as a writer the core thing is
not how beautifully you can string uh
words or sentences together the core
thing is do you [ __ ] have something
to say right and do you have something
to say that people haven't heard before
or that that that does something for
people this is ultimately the
competitive advantage and so I'm not
sure it's necessarily new but I think I
would agree with the idea that
um it makes it harder like Tyler Cowan
wrote a book several years ago called
average is over I think what these tools
do is is perpetuate that idea which is
that it becomes increasingly difficult
to make it being mediocre being pretty
good being okay right having something
not particularly unique to say I think
all these platforms get more and more
competitive or conversely there's fewer
and fewer spots because artificial
intelligence is doing the basic stuff
just like like look you used to be able
to make a living carrying boxes but now
a forklift can do that and now a robotic
forklift can do that you have to be able
to solve complex problems in a way that
a computer can't to to to sort of get
one of those jobs and I wouldn't be
surprised if you see that shift even in
the creative Fields yeah it makes
complete sense in Robert Greene's book
Mastery he talks a lot about
apprenticeship and I feel like part of
your success has been spending the time
to actually do the apprenticeship and
you may have thought about it that way
or maybe you didn't think of it when I
spoke with Robert one of the things he
said about you was uh that you and him
had talked multiple times that you
wanted to go write books and what is it
the right time should you wait you know
what was the pros and cons of Now versus
later how do you think in hindsight
about the apprenticeships that you got
with Robert and others uh and how
important was that for you to kind of
have the skill set uh and experience to
be able to be so successful as an author
today yeah I mean I don't think I'd be
talking to you without my time working
for Robert in fact I almost certainly
wouldn't and I I figure you you said
hindsight there this is another thing
where hindsight creates the clarity
right like uh
in retrospect I was Robert Greene's
Apprentice because we don't live in the
1700s and my father didn't sell me to
Robert Greene as an apprentice you know
in exchange for room and board
um these apprenticeships or these
mentorships you know I think people hear
about them and they go okay I need to go
find a mentor they go hey will you be my
mentor that's not how it works right
just like you you start spending time
with someone and then eventually you go
hey what is this are we like boyfriend
and girlfriend or you know what is this
that becomes clear after and so you know
I started for Robert transcribing
interviews that he was doing a thing
that you wouldn't to go to or what we
were just talking about that's the thing
you would not hire a person to do these
days right either the writer does it
themselves because they need to engage
with the material which I hear a lot
from a lot of creators about or
um now you can do have software do it
for you that's it's almost
indistinguishable but at that time I did
it so I started just transfer describing
these interviews and and then that
blossomed into more of a you know
occasionally I would ask Robert
questions and then he assigned me to go
research things and and over you know
five or six years I basically learned
not just
what a writer does and and and what a
writer you know what the writing life
looks like but I actually learned like
the craft of writing a book from start
to finish and you know I remember Robert
would often go like hey you know you
have to submit your hours to me uh like
so I can pay you and I was I'd be like
yeah I've not been recording them at all
I don't I don't obviously I need money
but like to me the the payment here is
that I want to learn how to do what you
do and uh the fact that you are
occasionally answering my questions is
the payment that you know I I was I was
ultimately after and and I think like
one way to think about this is like uh
there are people whose time you could
not purchase right like their time is
simply not for sale uh and so working
for them yeah you might be making twenty
dollars an hour or whatever the sort of
starting wage is for them but what
you're really getting is access into
their world into how they think uh into
the kind of advice that you know a
billionaire couldn't purchase and I
think ultimately that's what I got from
Robert is a sense of like how an idea
becomes a thing and and how you know one
has to approach the craft think about
the craft commit to the craft and I feel
like I'm still I'm I'm still in some
version of that apprenticeship with him
today although like at some point he
basically had to say like I'm not going
to give you research tasks anymore uh
I'm gonna give them to other people I I
would still I would still do it on the
side like if I could because I I just
learned so much and I mean often like
I'm still using things in my books today
that I that he had me track down like I
you could say some of my books are like
b-sides to Robert's books because there
are things that I found and I was like
Robert I think this is cool and he's
like nah it's not that's not for me and
I was like well I'm Gonna Keep it and
use it and so I I think it's really
important like whatever it is that
you're trying to do you find someone who
is world class at that thing and it
doesn't matter if you're getting them
coffee or sweeping the floors or you
know driving them around you need to be
in that orbit and and Learn by osmosis
most of all how they do what they do it
reminds me of the Warren Buffett quote I
think he says something uh paraphrased
around uh somebody asked for a job and
they said they would work for free but
that was too expensive for me and it's
all about like the time investment right
ends up actually being way more
expensive than any money he could have
spent
um but one of the things that Robert
said to me uh is the only negative thing
that he said about you uh and in full
conversation he said Ryan violated one
of the 48 Laws of Power he now outshines
the master
which it is interesting right like the
hope I think of every Mentor or coach is
that eventually they do teach people
whether implicitly or explicitly uh and
they go on and they're successful so how
do you think about uh taking the things
that you learned from Robert and other
maybe apprenticeships that you had and
like almost helping the people who work
with you now and really cheering them on
and hoping that they end up being even
more successful than you yeah I mean
that is the first law of power never
outshine the master and and it's true
you you have to be cognizant of the fact
that every single human being has pride
and ego that we have this sense of a
hierarchy of how the world works I think
it's it's to Robert's credit for for a
guy who wrote a book that starts with
never outshine the master and then
there's another law of power an equally
great one about uh letting others do the
work and and taking all the credit he
has been an incredible cheerleader of my
work and supporter
um I remember Robert referred me to his
agent uh who promptly turned me down uh
but but but Robert is always opened
doors for me and been and been awesome I
think he's being uh falsely modest when
he's saying that I I've I've outshined
him because I I know how many books
Robert has sold and and I will have to
be alive for a very long time to even
come remotely close to that but I think
he and I have had a great relationship
in that like Robert has shown me how
sort of traditional publishing Works how
the craft of things works and then on my
end as I've as I've figured out
different marketing things uh every once
in a while like you know a couple times
a year he and I get get together and I
go Robert here's what you need to be
doing on your end because your material
is going to crush so like uh with daily
stoic for instance like we had a lot of
success
um with Instagram reels and Tick Tock
like we were talking earlier and so I
set Robert Greene up with like a social
media manager and a video person that
every day uh Cuts up Clips like from the
25 years of of interviews that Robert's
done over the years and they post one a
day and every time I pull up Instagram
I'm like Jesus Christ did this video of
Robert do a million and a half views
today
um you know his stuff is so good that
for for Robert it's really about just
the same thing that I'm doing but but he
has this men's you know Decades of of
backlog and I think you're seeing you
know Robert's books have never sold
better than they're selling this year uh
and I think that's a testament to what
happens when you make truly great [ __ ]
uh all you really need to do is
occasionally you know update and tweak
and turn the dial as far as like the
distribution mechanism for that work and
it's always going to be relevant and uh
you know I think I think it it's it's
pretty amazing just to see like how big
uh Robert is like even in 2022 you've
dissected the manipulation of the media
previously uh and more so from uh could
you feed stories to the media and they
kind of run wild with it and use their
incentives against them but in some way
what you're talking about here is using
social media to manipulate the audience
in terms of Interest right it is a form
of media manipulation you're not trying
to trick someone at the New York Times
or some kind of mainstream publication
but in some way I almost feel like maybe
the algorithm is the publisher or the uh
kind of con content gate and if you're
able to put the right content in front
you see authors becoming very popular my
wife uh has been telling me about a
woman Colleen Hoover who's got like six
of the top 10 books she's the biggest
author in the world yeah and supposedly
it was all because of tick tock she like
became viral on Tick Tock and now she
has all these books and so how do you
think about the overlay of maybe like
old school media manipulation and things
you've written about there with like
this social media game and the algorithm
almost being a gatekeeper in some way so
like in in publishing even 10 years ago
right it was bookstores were The
Gatekeepers or the mechanism by which
you know most books were discovered
right there's there's some traditional
PR still at that point but like you know
you would walk into an airport and
there'd be this section of books that
are you know sort of new and noteworthy
and that was a paid game like any time
you walk into a bookstore and you see
books that are face out this is like out
of Barnes Noble or an airport or
whatever those books that that space
that uh that that promotional platform
is purchased it's called Co-op and so to
break through as an author you needed a
publisher and you needed a pretty large
marketing budget to get you in front of
people and then you think about actually
how small an audience you're competing
for there right like how many people
walk into bookstores in America on any
given day I don't know 500 000 people a
million that's probably high but you're
competing for those eyeballs and a
certain percentage of them already you
know what they want or they're not
interested in what you're doing so it's
it is a very small pie that a lot of
people are competing for now you you can
you contrast that with social media you
know however many millions of people are
on Tick Tock or Instagram or Facebook or
Twitter at any given moment and the vast
majority of them are not in don't even
know that they're interested in books
but but they potentially could be and so
what I think about with my stuff or
other authors I work with are Roberts is
I I try to think okay I wrote this book
I think this book would be interesting
to people who want to read books but how
do I take the core ideas in there and
break it it down into a piece of content
whether it's 10 seconds or 30 seconds or
30 minutes in a way that that uses these
algorithms which are the most you know
sort of powerful Media or cultural
forces on the planet and how do I how do
I get them to work for me right um I
think about this this is a very simple
one right it's like the reason we're
doing a video version of this podcast is
that podcasts have huge audiences right
but there's really no algorithm working
on the podcast medium right you have
your subscribers you put it out and if
people uh subscribe they hear about it
if they don't you know they don't right
the only thing that can drive new
followers to a podcast is Word of Mouth
people go hey I love this show you
should listen to it but on YouTube you
have an incredibly powerful algorithm
coupled with the second largest search
engine in the world and so the you know
by by doing a video version of it or uh
breaking that video uh you know the the
hour and a half or two hours we're doing
into Clips you now put yourself into a
position where YouTube is driving
significant discovery of your content
and so uh I just think a lot about how
do I how do I make the algorithm do the
hardest thing in the world for a creator
later which is surface your stuff to
people who have not heard of you I think
everyone who's created content on the
internet for long periods of time you
understand when you've kind of achieved
an unlock right you either learn
something or you realize there's a part
of the algorithm that you're able to uh
exploit in some way uh and when you do
that it almost feels like you've leveled
up to some degree but what I always find
interesting is that there's always new
platforms and part of actually
understanding where to create content is
selecting the platforms to double down
on and then the platforms to avoid on
and I'm sure you and I we've got a bunch
of mutual friends who will text you or
call you and be like there's this new
platform it's amazing it's gonna disrupt
Twitter and I'm always like maybe how do
you think about which platforms you guys
actually focus on versus maybe the ones
who actually are big but it's just not
worth your time or energy to go put
teams on it or even use your own time
and energy to uh to put content there
yeah there's definitely a first mover
advantage on a lot of these platforms
but I would imagine that the people who
are sort of Serial first movers I
imagine a lot of those gains are washed
out on the handful of networks that they
invested big in that didn't pan out
right so like I didn't do anything on
clubhouse and you know Clubhouse sort of
went like that right and so uh I I think
about not being I got this from Tim
Ferriss I don't want to be first I want
to I'm I'm happy to be later uh I just
want to be great on that medium and so I
think a lot of people are rushing to be
first and part of the reason they're
rushing to be first is that they've had
trouble getting traction anywhere else
uh one of the benefits too of like
having
traction on you know Instagram is that
when a new platform comes you tell
people to follow you on that platform
and you're not starting from zero on the
other networks either so I tend not to
try to rush to be first to anything I
try to sort of step back see how they
operate see what's working what's not
working and then I go okay well what is
a medium that uh or what what's a form
of content that I could do on that
meeting so like for instance on podcast
uh I was a little late to podcasts in
the sense that uh you know if I
obviously I have been on podcast since
you know the very beginning but but I
didn't launch mine until probably
2017 or 18 maybe even maybe even a
little bit later
um but but I had a big daily email like
the daily Stoke is one email a day and
so as I thought about a podcast I was
like you know what I'm not going to do
another interview podcast out of the
gate why don't I just read the daily
email and I'll have have you know a one
or two minute daily email podcast and so
that's how I started in and I didn't
start doing interviews until we were you
know hundreds of thousands of downloads
a month because we had this piece of
content that we knew was already working
we already had a a segment of our
audience that was asking us to do a
podcast and then we we expanded into a
new market from a position of strength
as opposed to what I think a lot of
people do which is you know they start
with nothing really doing nothing and
then they just hope to get very lucky
what I find interesting about uh social
media in opposition of books is uh books
as you mentioned are supposed to be
timeless or at least the best ones end
up being Timeless and so that takes a
lot of thought it takes a lot of editing
it takes a lot of concentration Focus
all the things we know that create this
like really high quality work but I also
have this theory that like your dumbest
tweets go viral and it's the one that
like you're taking a poop and you just
fire it off and you don't even think
about it next year though you come back
and you're like holy [ __ ] like that was
absolutely insane that that's the thing
that goes viral where I see an
intersection is that a lot of the uh
content you upload to Youtube appears to
be very high quality ideas but it's
almost like you're kind of like I'm in
my backyard or I'm like walking down the
street like like there's an element
where I get the sense that you're almost
trying to make it not super super high
quality but the ideas themselves are
high quality talk a little bit maybe
about you know the intentionality of a
book versus the the you know Serendipity
of a viral tweet and then how you think
about like the YouTube content and what
you're actually trying to accomplish
there today's episode is brought to you
by ftxus they're a safe regulated way to
buy Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've
got very cheap fees sometimes as much as
85 percent cheaper than their
competitors there's also no minimum fees
there's no withdrawal fees or any other
hidden fees ultimately FTX us is trying
to make it dead simple for you to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they also
now have digital stock trading as well
no transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code Pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today yeah I
think uh you know a book might take a
year or two years to write and you want
it to last for 5 or 10 or 20 years or a
hundred years right like I think people
will be reading the 48 Laws of Power 100
years from now uh and and so when you're
writing a book you're trying to write
something perennial or classic well and
and the expectation of the audience is
significantly higher because they're
paying for it right and and there's like
literally thousands of years of History
setting the bar for what is good or not
so that's why I like starting with books
because I know I'm making good stuff and
the medium is is a very unforgiving
medium so I want to start there and then
yeah what I sit down and do I use like a
this is actually my my GoPro rig which
is just you know a GoPro 9 I think with
an external mic and a tripod I use other
stuff but like that that can shoot in 4K
video so like let's say I just spent two
months you know writing uh a chunk of uh
the book that I'm working on well I've
been thinking about that every day uh
workshopping it kicking it around going
over it with my editor Etc well it's
really not hard for me to sit down you
know to set up the camera on a Ledge
somewhere uh stand a few feet back from
it and then just talk about that thing
for a minute or two minutes or five
minutes and then I can send that to my
Editor to break that down into you know
the tightest version of it you know they
can add some graphics or whatever they
can they can then take this thing make
it seem even more spontaneous than it
was and tighter than it actually was and
now I have you know a piece of video
that the algorithm can take and and put
in front of hundreds of thousands of
people or in some cases millions of
people so it's something I'm trying to
do necessarily lower quality stuff but
what I'm I'm trying to take this thing
that I have marinated on and meditated
with for a significant amount of time
and then I'm trying to to put it in a
different format really sort of quickly
and authentically yeah the the other
piece of this that uh resonates is
you're actually offloading to some
degree uh you're coming up with the idea
you're the one talking about it but
there is an external or an Outsourcing
of okay how do I take that idea and make
it like social media ready and there's
this editing component of it and what's
interesting I think is the different
platforms started out almost in
opposition to each other so you had
YouTube was super long form you had Tick
Tock which was super short form
Instagram was photos and because they're
competing with each other it almost
feels like they're all converging on
like 60 second or less vertical video
and so it changes the way somebody like
you or me or others that we know create
content because it's like well if all of
you are going to incentivize and reward
60 second or less vertical video we can
make it one time put on all the
platforms and like we win to some degree
and so do you guys think about that at
all all the time so so like a great
example is like I can shoot a 60 second
video uh I can send it I can have that
edited for ten dollars or whatever right
or if I have a full you know it's cost
next to nothing right cost nothing to
shoot cost nothing to edit I can put it
up I let's say I put it up on Tick Tock
and it does a hundred thousand views
okay now I know there's something here
well I can run that same video on
Instagram as an Instagram reel I have
multiple accounts I can run it on
multiple accounts I can also put that on
on Twitter uh as a short form video uh I
can put it on Facebook as a short-term
video and then uh if you know let's say
I've done that 10 times I have 10 60
second videos or I actually I just put
up a video on Friday that was 60 stoic
lessons each in one minute or less so
that's like a 45 minute video that is a
compilation of all those the the
short-term ones that that the algorithm
was already pushing I know that'll
probably do a hundred thousand views in
a it of itself now and each one of these
mediums monetizes itself differently
each one of these mediums tends to have
a different constituency so you're
putting their work in front of other
people
um I I I'm anywhere I'm getting double
triple quadruple efficiencies for the
same 60 seconds of time that I'm putting
in man like I'm I'm All About That
which platform are you the biggest on is
it Facebook Instagram where do you see
the biggest audience
uh yeah I mean I guess it depends like I
value things differently right so you
know a million views on Instagram is
worth more to me probably than a million
views on Tick Tock uh but you know 50
000 people uh signing up for an email
list is going to be way more than you
know to me than all of those because I'm
I'm actually owning that relationship
and there's not an intermediary platform
there I would say our daily email which
is about 500 000 people a day is
probably uh the biggest slash most
valuable of the audience the podcast is
like maybe five six million people a
month so that's very big uh Instagram's
probably after that YouTube's you know
some somewhere after that
as you think about those different
audiences different size one of the
aspects that when I asked you are you an
author a Creator or an entrepreneur is a
lot of the work that I've seen from afar
you think about it like an entrepreneur
yes you're a writer yes you're an author
but it almost feels like social media
you're putting content out you're
grabbing people's attention they say who
is this guy what are these ideas you're
then almost pulling them to the email
and then there you can recommend things
you can push your own book you can kind
of play this game as to you have the
attention you have the relationship how
intentional is all of this versus is it
just something natural where you're like
hey I want to get people as close to me
as possible and own that relationship
like talk a little bit just kind of that
Journey over the last few years of
building out kind of more of a business
around the writing it's a I think it's a
little bit of both I mean sometimes
people go oh you're just doing this for
the money and I go like if I'm doing
this for the money like talking about an
obscure School of ancient philosophy is
like the worst business decision I could
have possibly made and and and
specifically you know publishing
physical books in 2022 is you know not
exactly The Cutting Edge of uh you know
sort of scalable uh monetizable
intellectual property so
um I think first and foremost I I just I
genuinely love this stuff and this is
what I would be doing if there was a big
audience or a small audience but I I
remember I had a conversation with Casey
neistat like many years ago and he said
something he said two things which I
think about all the time he said look if
uh the two of us were doing this for
money we should just start an
advertising agency he's like that's
where the money actually is so like
we've already decided that that
maximizing financial gain is not our
primary priority and then he said the
second thing is with the money that you
do you make the reason you are making it
or should be making it is so you can do
more cool work right and and that hit me
in a in a really big way and one of the
changes I made in my business several
years ago which was you know after I got
into a certain amount of scale it was
like hey we have a budget here we can
advertise like we could you know we know
this is our audience I can advertise the
books I can advertise the talks whatever
I can advertise and then it occurred to
me one day that I was spending money on
advertisements which have zero s
positive social impact whatsoever and I
I made this shift right around the
beginning of the pandemic I said you
know what I'm not going to spend any
more money on Advertising I'm only going
to spend money on content I'm gonna make
more content not only because the
content is better at is better at
advertising than advertising is and it
has a longer shelf life but there is at
least a positive impact
to the content right like at the end of
the day I'm not going to care exactly
how many copies of my books on I've sold
I'm going to care how much impact has my
work had so uh there are like I'll see
this every single day right we'll post a
page from the daily stoic on Instagram
on an account called daily stoic and
people will go what book is that from
right and it's like from from the the
book of the thing that this is named
after that's the book and I realized and
I actually take this as a compliment
these people are consuming content about
stoicism and obscure School of ancient
philosophy every single day
for free and they don't know who I am or
that there's even a book about it right
and so obviously on the one hand that's
a marketing opportunity but but what
that really means is I'm spreading the
ideas out in the world in a in a way
that's reaching people who I otherwise
ordinarily wouldn't reach and so so a
big part of what I think about is is
like I just want to have as wide a
funnel as possible I want to be reaching
as many human beings as possible with
the work knowing that eventually they'll
trickle down and some of them will be
book buyers or whatever but as far as
like the actual way I I do the business
the the other thing I think about is and
I'm sure you see this with your stuff
which is when you have a really wide
funnel
um and this is what gets me excited
about the the you know sort of Creator
economy when you have a big podcast or a
big social media following or you know
whatever it is people want to buy that
space from you for advertisements right
the an Advertiser says oh that space is
worth ten thousand dollars to me because
they think they can make a hundred
thousand dollars in revenue from that
spot which means that actually the spot
is worth a hundred thousand dollars
right and so the way I think about it is
instead of selling that to a third party
who's going to take that 10x gain why
don't I just make stuff that I like that
I think is cool that is actually in line
with the ideas that you know my work is
based on and then I'll just use the
majority of that inventory myself and
you know so what I'm doing there you
know with these sort of philosophically
inspired products uh which have been
really cool as well as you know sort of
financially rewarding that's actually
the same Playbook that you know Rihanna
is using or the Kardashians are using
people with huge audiences are realizing
instead of doing a celebrity endorsement
I'm just gonna be an entrepreneur and
build my own Brands uh and and I think
to me that's the future of the Creator
economy
couldn't agree more uh and I love that
you're pointing out this is happening
all across uh you know kind of society
culture or whatever uh when you think
five years from now where does most of
the revenue come from is it the books or
is it some of these businesses is it
advertising dollars against the emails
and the podcast like how do you think
about maybe where your business is going
not so much where it is today yeah I I
think it's probably a mix of all of
those things
um I I could very easily go a hundred
percent in either one in any one of the
directions and advertising would
probably be the easiest uh because you
know all you have to do is record the ad
spot for LinkedIn jobs or you know
whatever the sponsor uh of that moment
is and I did a podcast deal with Amazon
wondering recently which is which has
been nice uh but I I think what gets me
excited about like the physical products
is that like I'm making something that
yes is for sale but ultimately you know
has some value in the world it is
codifying or you know helping people
apply the philosophical idea you know in
in a practice
um and you you think about this in music
like obviously a musician gets uh the
most excited about writing music and
recording music and releasing music but
they might make more money from touring
and they might make the majority of
their revenue from touring by selling
T-shirts on the road all of it is
funding the creative act which you know
got them inspired to be a musician when
they were you know 14 years old in the
first place
as you see kind of the business aspect
of this
um you're still publishing through a
publisher uh I don't know if you own the
publisher or uh it's an outsourced one
um and then you've got the bookstore
talk a little bit about the actual book
publishing components and like the
business there where do you see the
opportunity like in the bookstore to
actually go set up your own versus still
use kind of what I would consider legacy
infrastructure or just well established
kind of outside infrastructure yeah so I
I'm with penguin random house uh which
is I guess now the biggest publisher in
the world uh and I think they're trying
to merge with Simon Schuster which would
make them even bigger
um so I I work with a traditional
publisher for a couple reasons
um one uh I have self-published books
before and it is an insane amount of
work
um like much more than people think it
is at scale so look if you're if you're
sell if you're gonna sell a book if
you're gonna write a book that's going
to sell 15
000 uh physical units you should
probably self-publish it you'll make
more money
um it's not that difficult but if you're
gonna if you're gonna sell a book that's
gonna do a million physical units you
know over 15 years that that becomes
quite difficult uh that becomes not just
quite difficult but but financially
expensive to actually be able to pull
off right like uh who who pays for that
inventory who stores that inventory you
know who negotiates with the printer et
cetera so so I've worked with a
traditional publisher on most of my
books
um but I'm also in a space where I I get
large enough advances that
um it
it more or less makes what I would make
if I was self-publishing right or or it
guarantees that I will make uh what I
would make if I self-published a hit
right so I you know there's a certain
degree where I'm I'm taking some money
off the table by traditionally
publishing which allows me to take more
creative and entrepreneurial risks in
other domains of my life uh and then
um as far as the bookstore again not the
world's greatest financial decision but
part of the reason like I'll give you an
example I sold a four book series in
2000 the fall of 2019 uh which is the
one that I'm in the middle of doing now
so I did courageous calling uh
disciplines Destiny came out last uh uh
late last month I'm in the middle of
writing the third and the fourth one I
took the advance that I got for that
series and I bought two buildings here
in in in bastard Texas which are now the
headquarters for all this stuff that I
do and I have a bookstore downstairs I
wouldn't have been able to do that if I
was also paying for you know the
physical copies and and all this stuff
so so part part of what I use my
relationship with the publisher for is
to fund the other creative projects
where I I have uh more more creative
control and more uh upside uh to them so
I I see it as kind of a hybrid strategy
and the bookstore has been this you know
weird cool experience where
um I thought I was I I didn't exactly
think of it as a non-profit but I
certainly didn't see it as a huge money
making experience but it's actually been
a great you know a great you know let's
say small to medium-sized small business
um that's had a lot of rewards in
different ways but but it's been great
um down to the fact that I I launched my
last book out of the bookstore and
instead of instead of saying hey I have
a new book out go pre-order it on Amazon
I said I have a new book out pre-order
it from me and from my bookstore and I
because I can buy the the books uh as
cheap or cheaper from my publisher than
Amazon can I could beat Amazon's price
so this is fascinating to me because uh
I've heard different tidbits and various
conversations you've had uh the
bookstore when I first heard that you
got it uh I was like oh he's probably
gonna put his office there which sounds
like you have done yeah uh but then as I
started to talk to more people it became
more obvious that like maybe there was
an opportunity it was unclear whether
you were going to be able to do it if
you even wanted to do it but but this
opportunity that you're outlining is
I've seen in the emails and in various
Communications it's now not Amazon it is
your bookstore
um talk a little bit about how that
changes the economics of a book and and
I think people will be really interested
in this idea of like you as the author
get paid on every book that is sold but
the bookstore also makes a pretty
healthy profit when they do sell books
and so if you then combine the author
plus the bookstore like what does that
look like on maybe like a single unit of
a book that you've written well so I
think the core thing here is
distribution distribution is always the
most important thing to own so let's say
I'm I don't have my own bookstore but I
just have an email list with my own fans
and I say hey I have a new book coming
out you should buy it on Amazon or I say
you should buy it on Barnes Noble or you
should buy it on bookstore bookshop.org
I think bookstore. anyways there's a
Indie bound there's a couple independent
versions but the point is if you have
access to your audience and you say here
go buy it at this link there's affiliate
Revenue so Amazon pays like four to five
percent in affiliate Revenue so so even
back for the last 15 years when I've
been selling my stuff I've been getting
my 15 royalty from the publisher uh on
MSRP which is the standard thing that
applies against the advanced but I've
also been getting a four to five percent
kicker from Amazon that doesn't apply
against the advance because I have
distribution I have access to the
audience right and that's how all my
launch just went up until uh I guess
courage is calling
um and then what but but by then I'd
open the bookstore and I realized oh wow
I can actually order my books from the
publisher at roughly 50 off uh and then
I can resell them
to my audience uh and so I'm effectively
uh the math there starts to become
similar to self-publishing income but
without any of the risk and so uh it's
it's been interesting I mean it's
logistically quite onerous I mean I just
I
I signed 10 000 copies of the book
through the store and then I I
distributed and sold another 10 000
unsigned in you know three weeks of in
the last like the final three weeks of
September so like that that that's not
all profit in fact there's almost no
profit in there because I have to pay
people to do it and you know my almost
lost my hand
um it was it was it was a lot but to me
the reason I was doing it and when I
told my publisher I was doing it on the
series they said well you know you know
Amazon's gonna be a little upset Barnes
Noble's gonna be a little upset you're
you're stealing sales that these
retailers are you know want and I said
yeah but I want to control the the data
the relationship with the audience so
you know I think I did about uh fifteen
thousand uh maybe a little less than 15
000 on Courage but that was 15 thousand
people that when I launched the next
book in the series I said hey don't you
want the next book in this series and I
emailed them directly and now going into
the third book you know that list is 20
plus thousand customers not like names
on an email list that maybe are
interested but people who have purchased
from me before so I think at the core of
of what how I think about uh you know
everything other than the creative
process itself uh which I I try to keep
as pure and sort of driven by the idea
as possible everything else for me is
how do I own the relationship with the
person because you know I've I've
probably sold let's say I sold a little
over five million books let's say
three plus million at least of those
sales have come through Amazon right
over the last 10 or so years uh Amazon
has three million email addresses I have
none right and and and that's how it
works right you look at Colleen Hoover
huge
um she's let's say she sold 50 million
books and she has four million Tick Tock
followers that means she has access to
less than 10 percent of the people that
she that are her fans and I think every
Creator is trying to get that ratio as
high as possible and then when you put
in things like cancel culture and you
put in things like you know
the way these social media platforms you
know monetize themselves by by turning
the algorithm down and forcing me to
charge you know you want to be as
independent and direct as as humanly
possible that's that's your insurance
policy so I guess on the front end of
this how much pressure or conversations
have you had where the bookstore or
other things that you've done which I
would put under the kind of
characterization of just being
entrepreneurial have you had people say
Hey you know think about this before you
go and you do it
um and then also the second thing is
like does that lead to in any form or
fashion you worrying about cancel
culture or maybe I do something and my
book gets pulled from a certain Outlet
or something like that
yeah I mean uh I remember I sat down I
was with James Clear Mark Manson Shane
Parish uh
uh Tim Urban a bunch of other great
writers this is like maybe 2000 fall of
2019 right as I was thinking about doing
the bookstore and they were all like
definitely don't do it it is a terrible
idea
um and uh they were they were probably
right in a lot of ways but like to me uh
it was something I just it was just
something I felt like I I had to do and
I felt like it would be really cool to
do and what is the point of being
successful if you know all you're doing
is reinvesting that money in in [ __ ]
that you don't like or don't care about
and so to me like having the I mean I
love books like I've loved books and
I've Loved bookstores since I was a
little kid
having the bookstore to me is like you
know living in a 20 000 square foot
mansion like it's the dream man and so
um I definitely heard from people who
said it would be a bad idea for a bunch
of reasons and I and I took all that
criticism to heart I mean I think they
were not saying that I would fail I
think what they were saying is it's
going to be expensive and it's going to
take a lot of time so as I thought about
how I would do it I tried to mitigate
that in as many ways as possible I tried
to think about how can it be as lean as
possible
how can it be as you know uh resource
light as possible and and and I took
that feedback into account and I think
it's what's what's made it viable but as
far as like cancel culture stuff I mean
generally I try not to be an [ __ ] and
I I try not to to stick my nose in stuff
that's not my business I try to be
deliberate about what I do and say and
think I try not to be a you know uh a
monster uh as as uh unfortunately many
creative people are
um but of course there's a risk you know
sort of you maybe I did something and I
don't even remember you know early in my
life or or maybe I I uh the rules of
what society says are okay or not okay
shift maybe you just get really unlucky
I mean I think it would be naive to
think that uh just because you think
you're a good person uh means you can't
you can't ever find yourself in the
crosshairs of an Internet mob I mean of
course you can so to me my the way I
think about it is I want to be as
independent from the sort of mainstream
uh you know media ecosystem as possible
Right like
um look when you when you uh are part of
the club like when you have a boss then
you can get fired right and so I I've
just often thought about being as
independent as possible and even even
when I when I work with someone like I
do a podcast deal or I work with the
publisher I just I just try to
consciously go this is still a practice
go like yeah but would I would I be okay
losing this and as long as the answer is
yes then I feel okay doing it but I but
I don't I try not to take anything for
granted or assume anything is stable
because that is an illusion what's your
ultimate goal you talked earlier about
kind of killing off previous aspects of
your career or ideas uh but also you've
grown in certain ways as well it seems
like and so when you think about kind of
the ultimate situation or the ultimate
goal is it just to write books and just
keep doing that for the next you know 50
years is there some other goal that you
have how do you think about what you're
actually kind of driving towards yeah I
mean I I would like to get better at
doing this thing which is writing books
and and I feel like I am and and that
that's what I focus on you know I I want
to be a great writer but I also think
about you know uh there's obviously lots
of very great writers who are shitty
people like we were just talking about
and then maybe they're being canceled
for good reason and so I I try to think
about you know sort of being successful
in the space that I'm in in a way that
is still sort of conducive or
um
compatible with like being a regular
person in the world that you know takes
their kids to school in the morning you
know lives in a normal house uh has free
time to do what they want to do that
isn't a sort of bundle of nerves and
pile of stress that you know every sort
of waking moment I want I I like if you
if you think about like hey I want to do
this for the next 50 years
to me the the immediate takeaway from uh
uh an arc or trajectory that long is you
better figure out how to do this
sustainably or it's not going to work
right like uh
you're gonna burn out like either you're
going to explode or you're going to burn
you know grind yourself down into dust
so I I think a lot about Building
Systems and you know even setting goals
that are sort of
incremental as opposed to exponential
which I think make it harder to sustain
are there things that you've done
previously even the last couple of years
that you recognized hey if I continue
doing this it'll lead to burnout and so
you've pulled back or or stopped doing
them
yeah I mean look when when the pandemic
happened I didn't go on the road I mean
like my my family and I went different
places but like I did not spend a night
away from my family for 500 consecutive
nights which I'll probably never do
again but like those were probably 500
of the best not just best nights in in
that like we spent all this time
together but like creatively I was best
right and so coming out of it you know
as people go out things are going to go
back to normal I was like no way man I
don't want things to go back to that
kind of normal at all and so I've I've
had to I've had to raise prices on a lot
of things I've had to say no to things
I've had to be more disciplined about
you know now now that there's not a
compelling sort of Health reason not to
do stuff
um I've had to make up other reasons not
to do stuff if you know what I mean when
people see you as the successful author
uh and you can compare it to other types
of creators so I don't take Mr Beast I
heard him on an interview recently and
someone asked him you know what's the
craziest thing someone's ever asked you
to do and it was like a billionaire
offered 250 000 to do like a five minute
call with their kid have you ever gotten
some of these kind of crazy requests and
and I'm assuming it's not hey do a you
know FaceTime with my kid for five
minutes but like given the audience that
you're writing for yes it probably spans
a lot of different demographics and
wealth stats and things like that but I
do think that it probably leans towards
a lot of business people investment
people things like that what's the
craziest request you've ever gotten I I
haven't gotten offered anything like
that uh but I but I do and you probably
get this too
um one of the weird things about being
like a writer a creative or having some
sort of like sort of point of view that
you're known for is that like really
rich successful people like I don't want
to say they try to collect you but they
they they just like want you around so
you just get invited you're like a
you're like uh you know it's like anyone
can afford like any rich person can
afford to pay for an expensive dinner so
the the the the the the rare thing is
like who can they get to attend said
dinner right so you get invited to stuff
um or or experiences so like I have an
email in my inbox someone's like Hey
we're doing this like private all
expenses like hella skiing trip like you
have to get to this airport we'll put
you on a private jet uh we'll fly to
some you know place and then like the
helicopter will take us up and down the
mountain or you know I've been invited
to the Super Bowl a couple of times you
know like all just stuff like that I get
it you know hey Richard Branson's doing
this thing on his Island would you like
to come and like uh it all sounds very
cool
um but the pandemic was helpful for me
and a reminder of like what the
opportunity cost of that stuff is
um first off it you do this stuff and
you go this is just slightly fancier
version of a different thing still cold
skiing you know
um
but but you you sort of realize that the
cost is okay this is time away from
family this is time away from the
routine these are hours not put into the
work and I think when you work for
yourself and a lot of people experience
this during the pandemic suddenly you're
your own boss and you know nobody goes
hey Ryan you agreed to uh 50 more things
over the last year and we've Quantified
that and your book is now 16 not as good
as it could be right there's no math
that allows you to calculate exactly
what the opportunity cost of saying yes
to all this stuff was but eventually
there is that opportunity cost and
there's a lot of people who would like
to have my spot right and there there is
a lot of pressure from the audience uh
about you know what something needs to
be to be worth their time or energy and
I just I just try to remind myself that
you know everything I say yes to means
that I'm saying no to something else and
usually it means I'm saying no to the
most important things to me yeah what's
uh really interesting is one the more
successful you become whether
financially or kind of just career-wise
uh there's the old adage like everything
becomes free right all of a sudden now
you get invited to like the super
expensive dinner and no one expects you
to pay and you're like this is weird but
like okay thank you I think
um so like definitely that that
resonates but also this idea of the
routine and this is coming from you know
somebody uh from my side of in 2019 I
took 120 flights I was flying all over
the country I was doing all this kind of
crazy stuff and like that was just like
normal I guess and then similar
experience during the pandemic I was
like oh my God like if I go to sleep at
the same time wake up at the same time
in the same bed and do the same things
every single day like there's this
compounding effect and it's only been
three months of doing that now it's been
six months now I'm not like wow
yeah I I found that I used to be able to
work on planes I wrote big chunks of my
books on planes I could read on planes
uh and then you know and it was just
like it was a second home to me it was
no different than being in the office
there's no difference than being in a
hotel room it was just a place and then
when I took this huge break not being on
planes now planes are total dead time
for me it's obviously something I'm
working on because I don't uh you know
it I don't want it to be a dead time
like I'm I do have to occasionally be on
planes and as a result I need to figure
out how to to use that time productively
but it's also like I don't know if
you've ever radically changed your diet
you know you're like hey I cut out carbs
or hey I I went plant-based you make
some change
um and something you feel really good
you feel so much better and then you
have something from the old diet and you
feel like you're gonna be sick you're
like I'm be do I have food poisoning
this is horrible and you realize that
that fin was a kind of poison your body
was just acclimated to it was used to it
um like I don't need I tend not to eat a
lot of bread my wife is allergic to
gluten so like we don't have a lot of
bread in our house but I can't any bread
I just don't like then I'll be somewhere
there'll be pizza I'll eat a bunch of
pizza and I'll literally like just want
to die I'll feel disgusting and terrible
awful
um that's how I feel about planes now
and so
um
you realize that a lot of the things
that we accept As Natural are actually
fundamentally unnatural but not
conducive to being in your best uh you
know your best headspace your best
workspace and it's only by removing them
that you realize what the costs were and
so uh the other thing for me was it's
like I used to think oh you know you
take a week off and you recharge you
know the pandemic it took me months to
get to like where I ultimately got but
that was the best spot and now it's like
oh wow okay like when I take breaks I
need to take longer breaks they need to
be more complete breaks and this idea
that just like you know going to the
beach for the weekend is a way to
recharge you just realize you're
probably fooling yourself and it just it
just takes more and less than you think
I do think the pandemic was almost a
routine cleanse for people and what
you're basically doing is you're almost
like slowly adding things back to the
routine and it almost feels like maybe
you add something like oh nope that my
body is rejecting that or like my life
is rejecting that thing like get rid of
that again and just focus on this which
ultimately leads to this question around
as you want to get better and better at
writing are you now at a point where
you're like the Babe Ruth calling his
shot or you know when you publish like
this is a winner or or are you still
kind of like okay I think it's good but
like let's see what the audience says
like how confident I guess can you get
now given that you've written I don't
know 10 12 books whatever it is like do
you know that it is going to be
successful before it ever is published
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
in each sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep well there's always the
the humility and The Humbling nature of
what you talked about earlier which is
the thing you you jot off on the toilet
he just blows up and you're just like
whoa okay like there there is the thing
that in a fit of inspiration or a moment
of just you know dashing something off
you really hit something that's magical
that is always there and I'm glad that
it's there because it reminds you that
like you're not really in charge and
that like uh the the screenwriter
William Goldman uh famously said nobody
knows anything
um it's good to it's good to remember
that nobody knows anything and that
often what you think is going to work
doesn't work and what you're skeptical
about working works at a level
that you just could not have possibly
conceived I think about it less as the
Babe Ruth thing like I'm calling it
um but I think more about like I judge
what I do more about did I connect with
the ball right
um sometimes that goes all the way over
the fence sometimes it goes deep into
the left field but but uh somebody
catches it sometimes it fouls out but
like to me the important thing is did I
connect with the ball and I very
viscerally and very immediately feel
whether I connected and sometimes you
connect and you're like oh I really got
underneath that one and it's going all
the [ __ ] way that is a wonderful
feeling I mean that's the feeling you're
chasing I think any Creator is chasing
um but but I I try to think about it
more as did I connect because this is
the important thing so many external
factors determine whether that's a home
run or you know a ground rule double or
uh uh you know a single or or you know
worse right
um like with a book uh you know
I probably I almost certainly sold
enough copies on discipline's Destiny to
debut at number one on the New York
Times list but because I sold a lot of
those through my own store they didn't
count all of them and I was number two
so if success for me was uh
hitting number one and if because I felt
the numbers I said ah you got a number
one bestseller right here
um that would have been a rude and
unpleasant disappointment instead all I
was thinking from the write-in process
through the release was I'm very
confident that I've connected with the
ball here and that I've done all that I
can do here and that everything else is
extra so number two was great number one
would have been great but number 10 or
11 that is not on the list also would
have been great because because that
that feeling of connection is ultimately
like why I do it so I saw the video uh
where I think it's your publisher uh is
saying that you sold 60 000 copies in
the first week you debut as number two
on the list any part of you is like [ __ ]
I wanted to be number one right like and
uh what's interesting about it is like I
almost think you could be like [ __ ] I
want to be number one but I'm cool with
number two at the same time like how do
you think about having ambition but also
being satisfied with connecting with the
ball
so I I've hit number one before
um which was obviously wonderful and I
had a very similar conversation with my
agent you know hey but it's in
um and so hitting number one was was
great right so one of the benefits of
hitting number one is that like I'm now
a number one New York Times bestseller
no one could take that away it's like
you won an Olympic gold medal you're an
Olympic gold medalist right
um
six or six d uh is the same as one right
like you you got the thing you you did
it once
um there's a part of you of course that
I think uh would like to do it again but
I think one of the things that I've
taken away from hitting number one and
I've hit different lists and I've had
other like sort of cool [ __ ] is you
realize how little it actually means not
just to other people like it didn't
substantially change my life in any way
I don't think I sold any other books
blah blah nobody threw me a parade but
also like it didn't do whatever I
thought it would do for me right like
whatever part of me thought like my
dad's finally gonna be proud of me you
know uh I'm finally gonna feel good
about myself from you know whatever
whatever the thing we think we'll feel
when we hit that Financial number or we
win a certain amount or we take a
company public or we get Vindicated or
we win an election you know whatever
that thing you've told yourself is
happens
um
you are humbled by
not the emptiness of it because that
means that I think that makes it feel
like it's nothing but there is a part of
you that feels nothing because it is the
Stokes would say it is nothing it is an
external right it it wasn't something
you controlled it it it doesn't actually
say anything about you as a person and
it doesn't address you know what you
feel inside so
um
I I think I've done a lot of work where
I've gotten to a place where I truly in
New Orleans they have this word lanyap
which means like the 13th donut that
sometimes the baker throws in sometimes
they don't but it's just nice to have
I've gotten to a place where uh I've I
can I can actually see that stuff as
extra and nice but in no way like the
determining factor of whether I think
it's good or not
one of the best ways to get at someone's
focus and kind of what they care about I
think is how they keep score and so when
you think uh about your life today uh it
doesn't strike me that you keep score
based on how much money you make but
what do you keep score is it how many
books you sell is it the number of
people on an email list like when you
think of okay this is the score I'm
keeping and kind of what you measure
ends up being the thing you move what is
the score board or scorecard right now
yeah Epic 2 is one of the stoic
philosophers says if you only enter
competitions where winning is up to you
you will always win right and so
um obviously I'm a competitive person
I've always been competitive and it's
easy to be like okay I keep score by
copy sold I keep you know how many weeks
on the best seller list how much money
etc those are easy that's the external
scorecard
um but the problem is you do the
external scorecard is not up to you one
of what I think is one of my best pieces
of writing has sold the fewest copies of
any of my books and I don't want to say
that my best-selling book is my worst
book but what what
uh I I I am it's very clear to me when I
look at sales that quality and sales are
not as correlated as we would like and
certainly Awards critical exception you
know reception uh fan favorites these
are also decoupled from that so I try to
push that away as much as possible I and
and I try to go to a place where I I
determine I'm the square keeper right
which is like as an example am I getting
better better as a writer like is the
writing better according to me in each
subsequent uh project if the answer is
yes
um then I win and I get to decide that
now you might say oh that's a little
circular that's a way of cheating maybe
that holds you back uh that's not as
ruthless as say like you know copies
sold but when you realize that copies
sold
you know a lot of shitty books a lot of
copies you realize that's not really
such a good metric either so I try to
measure myself on that like
am I getting better at the thing itself
and is it more integrated into my life
as a person that's the other thing so
like I would say that each book that I
have done has been I don't want to say
easier because they've been harder in a
lot of ways but they have been less
disruptive in my life right
um they I have been more of a normal
reasonable uh
livable person to be with uh as I've
gone and that means actually a lot to me
you've mentioned family a couple times
and also being a livable person just now
um what have you learned about parenting
over the years and like maybe what is
like the study of the stoics help you or
hurt you in in terms of being a parent
well that that video you mentioned so my
agent calls me and goes hey you're
number two and my son I was in the other
room where I do a lot of my research my
son was sitting like uh on a chair in my
office and so no one was around so just
my son and I said hey Jonesy I just I
just hit number two and he runs into the
room and he goes can I watch YouTube now
and uh you know I think one of the
things that kids do is they just they
don't give a [ __ ] at all right like they
don't care whether you made a million
dollars today whether you lost a million
dollars they don't care if people like
you uh they don't care if they if you
like yourself they just care whether you
provide for them whether you're what
they need uh whether you're present and
fun and uh you know connected with them
and so I think one of the things family
does is it's I think people are often
people often think that family will hold
them back or hold them down and I would
actually agree with that it does it
holds you down on planet Earth when your
ego wants to take you up you know when
things want to go to your head when
you're when you're uh
able to spin off the planet because
everyone enables you tells you you're
awesome because you you know there's a a
line from Bertrand Russell I like he
says the first sign of an impended
nervous collapse is the belief that your
work is terribly terribly important and
and family kind of reminds you that it's
not terribly important right like like
they're like why aren't you home we're
having dinner you know and so I I think
being rooted and connected to reality is
the most important thing and when I when
I look at like you know famous people
that are spinning off the planet I'm
like that's a person who I mentioned
this or that's a person who did not do
school pickup today right like that that
that's a person who did not have to get
up in the middle of the night with a
crying baby that I I read a thing about
um uh lin-manuel Miranda he was talking
about when Hamilton blew up uh like his
first child was born like as they were
doing the dress rehearsals for Hamilton
and he was saying that and I think about
this a lot it drives with my experience
as Hamilton became the biggest thing in
culture and it was making millions of
dollars and famous people were coming
every single night he had to leave
immediately after the show to go home
because he had an infant uh because he
actually took his duties as a you know
father seriously but he also knew hey if
I go out to this after party and I get
home at two well a baby's gonna wake up
wake me up multiple times in the middle
of the night and then I'm not going to
sleep well and I'm not going to be able
to perform tonight and so I he was
basically saying that having kids kept
him honest and I think that is a really
really important uh part of this like it
is so easy as suddenly your Works
reaching millions of people suddenly you
know you move this thing around on your
computer and you're moving huge amounts
of money around so the president is
calling you or you know whatever the
thing that you're in the position of
success or influence that you wanted
you've worked so hard for you get it
but to maintain it you have to be rooted
and you have to be connected to reality
and I think kids are an incredibly
important counterbalance to the to the
selfishness and ego and and uh uh you
know uh busyness that that successful
people can be sort of like a moth to a
flame to so the first thing is I now
think your son's a genius because he
knew you were in a good mood and asked
to go watch YouTube So yeah so
capitalizing on the opportunity uh but
but the other piece of this is a lot of
people do focus on like how do I reach
you know the Pinnacle of my career how
do I reach that accomplishment but
really what you're talking about is like
once you get there actually the great at
whatever they do it's the ability to
compound and stay there for decades
right you talked earlier about you know
Robert being able to sell books more
books this year than he ever has before
and that is just the ability to continue
to stay focused and the ability to keep
that discipline which is part of what
you write about in the book and I
thought the the section on Lou Gehrig
was uh just really spoke to this whole
idea of uh the hard work day in day out
it doesn't matter what's going on if you
continue to do that people may not
notice on the day-to-day basis but over
this long period of time it becomes very
obvious to people like this person is
different this person is great this
person uh is able to do something the
rest of us aren't
yeah I mean first off to go to the idea
of like the true grades like when you
look back at your life you're not gonna
you're not gonna think about you know
how much money you made uh how
successful you were Etc if you know
you're alone if all you want is for your
kids to answer your phone or you know
answer the phone when you call like
success at the end of your life I've
said this before is a crowded table
right it's like family and friends that
want to be around you and I think I know
you you've probably met them you meet
really successful people and you're like
this is the Loneliest [ __ ] person in
the world like this is that I would not
trade places with this person right and
so so you know first off it's it's
defining what success actually is and I
think there needs to be a sort of a more
holistic definition uh but yeah like
what's fascinating about Lou Gehrig and
I read a ton about him as I was he's the
the first he's he's who I have embody
the idea of physical discipline in the
book
um
he's so well known for his streak of you
know 2100 consecutive games that his
stats are almost totally forgotten but
because he consistently played and
played consistently well he's like the
all-time leader or on the all-time
leaderboard still for some of the most
impressive statistics in baseball I mean
he batted 500 in multiple World Series
right uh he had an insane career batting
average an insane number of home runs he
won uh multiple batting crowns multiple
RBI crowns you know uh he was just an
incredibly he he wasn't like the
greatest but because he was consistently
good for so long for such unlong
uninterrupted periods
um his numbers are up there with most of
the all-time greats it'd be like
obviously Aaron judge had this
incredible season but if Aaron judge
consistently hit 40 to 50 home runs like
every year uh for like 20 consecutive
years I mean just imagine where he would
be and and that's effectively what Lou
Gehrig was we we talked about Babe Ruth
calling that home run uh Lou Gehrig hit
two home runs in that game too right uh
he he was just one of the all-time
greats because he was consistently
so good
my wife and I always talk about uh our
life changed when we got to a point
where we would go meet these hyper
successful people and and you feel so
fortunate and like oh my God I'm gonna
learn so much from these people or
whatever and then we would leave whether
it was dinner or an event uh you know
it's time at their house or whatever and
we'd always ask ourselves would you
trade lives with them and as you just
mentioned uh it's kind of crazy when all
of a sudden you're like no I wouldn't
like this big multi-billionaire with you
know all the crazy stuff and and this
crazy life and they're flying around the
world and all and like I wouldn't trade
lives with them like you almost feel
again you've like unlocked a different
part of life that uh for some people not
it's not for everyone but for some
people they really feel like uh it's
more rewarding to uh to live you know
maybe the life I live or the life you
live
um which is kind of a crazy thing
because it's as a kid that's not what
you think is you know the Pinnacle of
success well it's it's funny I um uh
probably one of the most viewed like uh
Instagram reels or tick tocks that I
ever did I told this story about Kurt
Vonnegut and Joseph Heller Kurt Vonnegut
wrote Slaughterhouse Five uh uh Joseph
Fowler wrote Catch-22 two of the the
most successful fiction authors of the
you know mid 20th century to the to the
great writers of all time and like we
were talking about you get invited to
these parties and they're in they're at
some uh party outside New York City
probably in the Hamptons of some you
know billionaire and uh Vana get his
teasing Heller and he and he says you
know how does it feel to know that this
guy probably made more money this week
than than Catch 22 will make in your
lifetime and uh Heller goes yeah but I
have something that he doesn't have and
kurvanagan says what could that possibly
be and Heller says I have enough right
like I he says I know what enough is and
enough is the the wealthiest place you
could possibly be right like if you feel
good uh and and happy making a hundred
thousand dollars a year uh you are far
wealthier than someone who made a
hundred million dollars last year but
has come comparing themselves
ceaselessly and relentlessly to someone
who made 120 million dollars last year
right
um one of the stoics said that uh
poverty is not having too little it's
wanting more now obviously poverty is
real and if you can't pay for you know
uh your kids diapers or uh your car is
broken down you're gonna have a hard
time uh just going through life so I'm
not trying to be glib but what I am
saying is that after a certain point uh
it is jealousy it is comparison it is
insatiableness that is you know the
poorest place to live or be because it
doesn't matter what you do it doesn't
matter how what people think about you
you're always going to be focused on but
does this person have more why didn't I
get this well what if I reinvest this
can I get this you know there's no like
law that says you have to make more and
more and more and more but but we sort
of just because we don't really know
what we want we don't really know what
we want our lives to be I think we just
intuitively and instinctively try to
acquire more and more and sometimes this
is good but a lot of times it makes us
profoundly unhappy
obviously uh your study of the stoics
and a lot of their work uh is really a
Pursuit of Happiness along with many
other things I thought we could spend a
few minutes talking about some of the
the stoic uh philosophy in in some of
the events and a great place to start
would just be like how do you balance uh
maybe the aspirational element of
controlling emotions and happiness and
like all these great things that we read
about and then when you actually learn
about history you're like you know
Marcus Aurelius and Commodus and like
their wives are being killed uh and like
just like the the crazy ruthlessness of
the times with also like the writings
that seem to be what we all aspire to
one day you know live that life like how
do you kind of balance those two things
no I think it balances the right word
because if you just read the stoic's
writings you get this sensor like oh you
know no amount of external success
matters or like don't care what other
people think or Focus only on what you
control et cetera Etc
um and you can get this sense that like
oh the result is they became these like
monks who lived in the Hills somewhere
and didn't participate in life because
maybe all that's meaningless or outside
of their control but you know you think
about Seneca Seneca is one of the most
powerful politicians in Rome he is uh
one of its most successful business uh
men and on the side he writes these
beautiful haunting plays that are so
popular that actually at Pompeii you can
see a line of graffiti that is a line
from one of seneca's plays it's
preserved there for for all time so
Seneca was a person who did stuff and
the Stokes got married and they had kids
and they worked jobs so I I think what
it is and the way I think about it is
look if you're an ambitious talented you
know sought after person
you need to be reminding yourself hey
these external things don't matter hey
Focus only on what's in your control hey
you can't take this money with you when
you die you need those reminders you
already take for granted that you know
doing great work is important that you
should strive to maximize your potential
right that that uh you should try to
shape the world for the better you
already have taken all this for granted
but but it's it's so easy to take that
to excess right to think that you're the
center of the universe to like we're
saying that your work is terribly
terribly important you need to balance
it out and so when you read a book like
meditations I think what's so incredible
about is you have the most powerful man
in the world writing notes to himself
little reminders like hey look this is
important but losing your temper doesn't
make things better for people you know
he goes hey like yeah your job is to is
to manage all this stuff but your real
job is to be a good person right that
that is what ultimate success is and so
I think the stoics were like exactly
like you and I exactly like a lot of the
people that were that are listening to
this right now they're ambitious they're
driven they're talented uh that they're
busy Etc
these are the people that need these
reminders the person who's never going
to get up off their couch who doesn't
care who isn't trying
they got it under control you know this
is not a concern for them right it's
like ego ego is a huge problem but not
for losers right you know like ego is a
ego is a disease of success right uh it
is a problem it is a thing that will
destroy what you have built uh and so so
I think it's we're the people that need
these things more than anyone else I
think a lot about like ambition is an
ingredient for both success and ruin but
if you're not on the outliers of the of
those two things and you're just kind of
like you go through life you're not too
successful you don't ever meet ruin
ambition may not really be a key
ingredient to uh to surviving right yeah
I I heard someone talking about like all
these social uh social entrepreneurs
right they're like and we're gonna
donate a percentage of our profits to
charity and he was joking he's like you
should probably have profits first right
and so sometimes we get carried away
with this stuff like thinking about it
when when it's real it's not even an
issue for us it's like tax tax planning
when you're making you know twenty
thousand dollars a year this isn't
something that you need to think about
but suddenly when you know the business
takes off yeah if you're not thinking
about it you're going to be leaving
opportunities or gains or or or or or or
or or profits on the table and so uh
yeah you can get carried away uh
obviously but but it's really at the
highest level when the stakes are when
the stakes really matter that you know
ego and uh excess and ambition all these
things start to be really worth paying
attention to so it's obvious the stoics
obviously uh in their lives they made
mistakes they did crazy stuff whatever
but in their writings is there anything
that you vehemently disagree with or you
think that they like got wrong
that's a good question I mean look the
the
realm of you know that period was a
hierarchical stratified society in which
individuals had like no agency right so
like I'll give you an example
um
almost none of the stoics questioned
slavery uh including Epictetus who was a
slave right like he gets free he he
frees himself from slavery uh and he
talks about why it's not good to be a
slave like as a metaphor but at no point
as you go hey it's pretty [ __ ] up for
one human to own another human and we
should you know disregard this
institution uh or or do something about
this uh institution and that was because
I think the stoics The Stokes were so
focused on what was in our control
versus not in our control and so uh
focused primarily on individual choice
that I think they missed a lot of
opportunities for Collective action and
the 2000 years since you know Epictetus
or Marcus really is we have been uh the
recipients of the Learned experiences of
people who did things that or changed
things things that we didn't think were
possible like I'll give you an example
let's say you were a student of the
stoics and you lived in the American
South in the 1930s you might personally
not be a racist you might personally
think that segregation and Jim Crow was
a moral Abomination but maybe you would
say to yourself This is an injustice
that's outside of my control and so I'm
going to focus on being the best person
that I can and I'm going to have to
accept that this is when I was born and
this is when I live right it's not until
uh the civil rights leaders uh Diane
Nash Martin Luther King Malcolm X come
along and go actually hey if we all come
together and we exert certain pressures
and we stop focusing only on what we
individually do but on what we can
collectively accomplish we can change
these things and so I think one of the
areas that stoicism struggles at least
in the historical record
is their ability to come together and
bring about Collective change which is
perhaps outside of the individual's
control but if all individuals think
that no change is possible you know what
I mean yeah completely and
um one of the ideas that when people
read about stoics or they or they study
it and they learn about it they start
thinking modern Stokes like who are the
people who are going to be the the
modern you know version of the stoics um
so I wouldn't be interesting to hear
your ideas as to like who those people
may or may not be but also whenever I
hear people talking about it they
constantly jump to like well who's
trying to create change right who who
are the people which almost is in
opposition to the way that the stoics
actually were and so when you think of
the modern day are there certain people
who are either public or maybe even
private that you think really embody uh
uh maybe the stoic lifestyle or
philosophy and then also like is there
an overlap where maybe the stoic version
of the modern day is like the people on
social media who are calling for Change
and are successful early or how do you
kind of think through that yeah I mean
it's interesting I um
I think George Washington right is this
sort of example of the tension there so
George Washington bases his entire life
on cada one of the great Roman Stokes
that's his hero that's who he models all
his decisions on and obviously uh
Washington was wrongly resigned to
certain sort of parts of uh culture and
America at that time
but by another definition he creates a
new country from nothing with a small
ragtag group of individuals so I I think
there is a tension in the stoics where
sometimes they're too resigned but at
their best they're absolutely on the
Forefront The Cutting Edge of change
action you know inventing new things
making new things so I I don't I don't
want to paint the stoves with too broad
a brush that like the stoics never uh
engage in social change
um of course they do and they and they
always have although I I had Stacy
Abrams the the the politician on on the
podcast a while ago and she actually
when she lost that election in Georgia
she said I'm not going to be stoic about
this I'm going to do something about it
and you know she ends up obviously
creating this voting rights organization
that swings uh the the 2020 runoff uh
probably wins Biden Georgia and thus the
election and then certainly is the is
the Catalyst for the Democrats taking
the the Senate uh in that runoff now you
can say that this is good or bad or you
agree with it or disagree with it but my
argument to her was that's actually the
definition of stoicism on the one hand
you took something that you felt was
unfair and unjust and you didn't
complain about it you didn't whine about
it you didn't quit take your ball and go
home but you you disagreed with what
happened and then you set to work
affecting change in response to what had
happened and so to me that's that's what
stoicism is I don't I don't feel the
need to say she is a stoic but I would
say that approach is itself stoic when
we say look I don't like how things are
I object to how things are I understand
that there might be large swaths of this
that I simply have to accept but there
are parts of it that I do not accept and
because I believe I have the ability to
change them I am going to get to work at
at doing so right if nobody believed
they could change the world the world
would never change yeah when I ask
people for questions uh there was a
bunch of folks who basically were like
look I get it stoicism is this amazing
thing he's done a bunch of work there I
never hear him talk about X and some of
them I had heard about some of the my
Hatton uh one of them was like Tau
teaching and many other types of
philosophical views of the world and
things like that because you've been so
focused on stoicism do you look at other
areas of focus do you compare do you
feel like you can learn or are you just
like hey look stoicism is the thing I'm
most focused on everything else is cool
but like that's not really my focus no I
I definitely try to read very widely
Seneca says we should we should read
like a spy in the enemy's Camp right
that we should we should always be
reading uh people we disagree with and
what's fascinating about Seneca is the
philosopher that Seneca quotes the most
is not a stone it's epicurus right the
founder of epicureanism like his rival
so I I try to read accordingly and
actually my book Stillness is the key is
is rooted in the stoic concept of
ataraxia or Stillness
um but I I I I quote quite liberally
from the Dao de Jing uh from uh from
Confucianism and Buddhism uh and and and
Christianity as well like I'm not I I'm
an agnostic I'm not an atheist but I'm
not religious uh and I I quote from the
Bible all the time uh and I've read it
many times and so I I try to read quite
widely and study these other schools
stoicism happens to be what I come home
to and what I have found because of this
reading to stand up the best but uh but
I try not to close my mind to this other
stuff for sure
when you think of all the work that
you've done all the people you've
studied is there one quote that you come
back to and you're like this is the
quote that describes my life or this is
the thing to like put on my Tombstone
the day I die that really just kind of
stands Head and Shoulders above
everything else
I mean I go back and forth I think
what's so lovely about the Stokes is
like you you crack them open and then
whatever you need at that moment is
there I think the zhajin is the same way
uh the Bible can be the same way it's
like when the student is ready the
teacher appears right you find what you
needed to hear in that moment because
you bring to it something that maybe is
not even actually there but um there's a
there's a line at the beginning of
meditations that I've thought a lot
about in the last couple of years
um Mark cerealis is talking about what
he learns from this philosophy teacher
he has named sextus and he says um that
he learned to be free of passion but
full of love and I love that because it
doesn't it doesn't sound like stoicism
the the free of passion part does but
the full of love part baby doesn't and I
like that as a kind of counterbalance to
this idea of stoicism being harsh and
unfeeling and you know driven and
robotic I I like the idea that the point
is to take away these destructive
emotions so what there's room for is
empathy and connection and and love uh
and I don't think he just means love for
other people I think he also means like
a love for you know the moment of time
that you're in for the situations that
you're in for the hand that life has
dealt you even if those are not what you
wanted even if other people might think
that that's a really shitty hand the
idea of being full of love that's not
something I consistently able to do but
it's what I aspire to do
the last thing I want to talk to you
about is this idea of death drives focus
and you've written a lot about kind of
mortality and and the mental focus
there's many other people who have
referenced this
um but what's interesting about it is it
really gets at this idea of time and the
finite amount of time there's a concept
uh that Graham Duncan uh popularized uh
time billionaire that that just I think
really hammers this home how do you
think today given all of the things
you've done in your life uh you know
you're around the age of the midpoint
right if you're fortunate enough to kind
of live till till uh life expectancy or
whatever
have things changed do you think about
it differently than maybe you used to
death drives Focus like what kind of
just comes to mind when you hear those
phrases and kind of that those ideas no
I love that concept I mean we were
talking about wealth earlier if you
don't have time how rich are you you
know like when if you don't command or
control your schedule how powerful are
you really now I get like obviously
you're the president or whatever uh you
know there's this period where you're
accepting that for some time you don't
control your schedule but I think so
often we conflate busyness with success
and uh when I when I don't have time to
do the things I want to do whether
that's read write spend time with my
kids work out like if I have a a
jam-packed day like when I pull up my
calendar and it's [ __ ] full I'm like
this sucks right this is not success
this is like like I'm one step away from
having to put on a suit and you know be
at an office right like that's not what
I want uh I want I want autonomy so so
my definition of success has always been
autonomy and that I can say what I want
I can think what I want and I can do
with my time what I want
um and the reason we we have to Value
time over these other things is that
time is the most precious resource it's
the only non-renewable resource
um
Seneca makes this fascinating point he
said exactly what you were pointing out
that I'm at the midpoint
um you know we tend to think of death as
this thing in the future he says that
we're moving towards but he says this is
the wrong way to think about it he says
because the time that passes belongs to
death like every minute that's passed is
dead forever and so he says we're not
dying once at the end we're dying every
minute every day and so if you think
about it that way to me it it puts in
Stark relief like how One chooses to
spend their time and one of the most
powerful questions in in meditations
Marcus because are you afraid or he says
he says Are You Afraid Of Death because
you won't be able to do this anymore and
he means this as a blank like like
you're like uh you know in some boring
ass conference call and he's like you're
afraid of dying because you won't be
able to be on any more conference calls
right and and and and and and I think
that's a really powerful way to think
about obviously there's some stuff you
have to do in life uh that that that you
don't want to do and if you lived as if
you were for sure going to die tomorrow
you would probably not actually live a
very good life but if you can live as if
death is always a possibility I think it
gives you perspective and Clarity and
focus
it's a great place for us to end uh I
could not agree more your new book
discipline is Destiny is New York Times
bestseller where where should we send
people to uh to buy it not Amazon
uh just go to dailystoke.com discipline
or you can come to my bookstore the
painted porch uh in Bastrop Texas the
next time any of you are in Austin
awesome Ryan listen thank you so much I
really appreciate it I know that a ton
of people uh enjoy your writing uh the
various books that you put out all the
social content and we'll definitely do
this again in the future thanks for
having me let's do it in person next
time